Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata di
Cucina Buttata, un po' di tempo fa
abbiamo fatto un tiramisù utilizzando la
testa di un dinosauro e l'esperimento non è
andato benissimo. Ora il tiramisù
effettivamente è una cosa che tutti
quanti sanno fare e quindi molto
probabilmente penserete di non aver
bisogno di guardare questo video, e
invece no perché oggi cercheremo di fare
un tiramisù un pochino diverso dal
solito, un pochino più...
- Prefessionale (Chef Mario) - Professionale, grazie Gianmarco
Ed ecco perché non lo farò io ma lo farà Irene Tolomei, con la pasticcera che
conosciamo perché faceva box con Enrico
fondamentalmente e andavi a scuola al
liceo con Roshane - Con Roshane si - Oggi che facciamo
praticamente? - Facciamo il tiramisù più
spettacolare della tua vita - Ammazzare che intro! (Rico) - Allora praticamente facciamo una palla di cioccolato. Dai si vedono
tantissimi video - Di palle si, ne vedo tante sisi - Con dentro il tiramisù - Quelli che si
sciolgono - Esatto, poi ci mettiamo sopra il caffè, poi si scioglie, un botto di like, un botto di follower - Perfetto!
Quindi a questo punto io direi innanzitutto di cambiarci
perchè così tu hai il tavolo
davanti, visto che io non farò niente
E di soprattutto inaugurare, com'è che si chiama la
parannanza, il grembiule? - Il grembiule
Grazie si. ll grembiule dell'ospite.. Per fare il tiramisù più
spettacolare che mangeremo mai nella
nostra intera esistenza avremo bisogno
di: zucchero, farina 00, uova pasta gialla
- Uofa, si dice così - Cioccolato fondente
Ma questo qui è un cioccolato particolare? - Si è un cioccolato con una percentuale di burro di cacao
maggiore - Oggi se siete delle persone
basse e pezzenti a noi non ce ne frega
niente perché oggi noi rinnegheremo le
nostre origini - Fecola - Mascarpone. Ma questo è
per darci la carica? - Si se non viene poi... - Ti ubriachi
- Marsala... - Robe - E robe da fichi. La parte esterna della fava di
cacao che è stata seccata, tostata e poi
un po' anche... - Smandrappata -Smandrappata ecco
in termine... - Tecnico - Che cosa dobbiamo fare quindi? Vabbè ci manva la panna che sta nel mio zaino
- Ah vero. Quando Irene ha detto a Gianmarco quali
sarebbero stati gli ingredienti per questa
ricetta a "panna"
lui ha portato la panna, quella per fare la
carbonara francese, invece no panna
fresca, direttamente dal suo frigo. Una professionalità
pari a zero. C'è il caffè è vero, ci siamo dimenticati
il caffè, ma è così importante in un tiramisù il caffè?
- Partiamo subito con la parte più
difficile: savoiardi - Comprarli faceva schifo vero? No è un po' da poracci capito? Così adesso ti odieranno tutti
Eh è vero, è colpa eh ragazzi - No vabbé vengono più buoni, più friabili, più tutto. Se vengono bene
Se vengono bene. Ragazzi io mi sento proprio una pippa vicino a te, e sono pieni di aria ancora
Beh puoi anche non pesarli, tanto sono tre albumi no? Non per metteri pressione però se va una sola goccia di
tuorlo all'interno dell'albume non monta
correttamente - Non per metterti pressione
naturalmente ma io è da una vita che separo
tuorli dagli albumi - E puntualmente
casca (Rico) - Una goccia di tuorlo - Sei un po' lento però - Guarda quanto sono veloce adesso
Una volta vorrei provare quello che si vede su internet
tipo con la bottiglia - Si con la bottiglia che devi aspirare
- Secondo me si rompe tutto fai un casino - Guarda che questo qui è stato un ottimo metodo. Vuoi una carezza?
Vabbè per renderlo - Croccante. 45 grammi di
zucchero, 45 grammi di zucchero - Ok
Mazza che memoria ferrea (Rico) - Io tipo dovrei
leggere per avere questo ricordo...Li montiamo insieme? - Più o meno, adesso vedrai..."Così"
Non ci arrivano mai solitamente
ma perché così c'è il calore materno
capito? - Ma ti prendo la prolunga? (Rico) - No guarda sto così bene...Che produzione
Ma è enorme sta spina! - Metti qua
Stanno schiumando quindi aggiungiamo un po' di
zucchero - Ah- Vai
- E ora posso?...Ma è vera la cosa
che le ragazze se hanno le mestruazioni non
si monta l'albume?...- Non l'ho mai sentita. Dove l'avete letto sulla "femminile?" - "Io donna"
50 grammi di farina e 17 di fecola - Ok
- Quindi - Perché mettono la farina qua? - Non lo so...Vai. Ops...Marisa la spatola
Aspetta che ti do Marisa - Dobbiamo prepararci con il sac a poche. Secondo te si dice il sac a
poche o la sac a poche? - Allora secondo
me si dice il sac a poche perché tutti dicono la sac a
poche - E' vero - Ma ti va bene anche una Marisa così?
Ok che non ti aiuterà come quelle più professionali però...
- Sono come quelle che usiamo in pasticceria - Ti regala il sorriso esatto
- Aspetta un altro po' sennò stiamo fino a
domani. Lentamente dal basso verso e giri la ciotola...nell'altro verso. Bravo!
Che fai lo smonti? - Ah no così si smonta? - Devi trattarlo
come... -Come se fosse un figlio - Sì esatto, cioè una tua creazione
- Non ci sta il lievito - Alla fine i savoiardi fanno parte della famiglia dei pan di spagna - E nessuno ci
crede mai quando lo dico lo sai? - Io te ne faccio uno e tu fai gli altri
- Ma abbiamo invitato una sadica in questa cucina?
Io invece uso sempre lui al posto di
Marisa perché mi dà felicità quando
quando giro e poi è scomodo, e
almeno puoi sempre dare la colpa lui e non a
te stesso. Mi sento Antonella Clerici un pochino. E quindi come funziona? - Adesso si mette il
cremo (Rico) - Guarda attentamente - Sul padello il sac a poche col cremo - E inforniamo "così"
Li facciamo mini o big? Tutti e due così... - Ok si
Big...così. Oppure mini...Secondo me sono più carini
Allora li farò tutti i mini - Le ultime parole (Rico)
- Allora non è un mitra comunque
- Madonna! (Mario) - Eh sembra un po' una lumaca - Io avrei detto un c***o
Enrico facci vedere tu che... - Secondo me Enrico è bravo per questi lavori (Mario)
- Si ma lo sta tenendo come un mitra - Scusa un attimo...Vabbé il primo eh - Meglio del mio
E' strano non vuoi fare un pene? (Guglielmo) - Quest'arma è demoniaca
Ti prego faglielo fare a Gianmarco - Gianmarco ti prego - No no (Gianmarco) - Ti prego Gianmarco (Enrico)
Ti prego facci vedere come non si fa -Tengo qua - Si ma non così - Ma come tieni tu?
Ma poi da sette metri (Guglielmo) - Io darei una piccola spolverata di
zucchero a velo che non abbiamo - Sisi
Non l'hai portato? Oh no
Ecco lo zucchero a velo - Vai vai. A quindi li hai fatti tutti, quindi se va male uno vanno male
tutti in pratica - Si, e io ti ringrazio per
avermi fermato proprio quando ho finito l'ultimo
- Inforniamo 10/15 minuti in un forno a 180 gradi
L'ho appena letto - E hai letto pure male perché c'è scritto 20 minuti
- Quanto lo devo mettere al microonde? - Dagli un po' di step da 30
secondi - Ti prego allontani questa cioccolata da me?
E' buonissimo - No allontanali pure da me però (Enrico) - E che cavolo!
No no vai vai, dagli una mescolata casomai col cucchiaio perché sennò si brucia - Si?
- Non hai mai bruciato il ciocco...come, cioè un
professionista del tuo livello non ha mai...
- Non ho bruciato il cioccolato te lo giuro
- Ammazza - E' pazzesco...Ah eccolo qui - Tasty - Esatto, esatto! - Meno piedino gli facciamo sopra meglio è
Cerca di rimanere sempre dentro alla sfera. E controlliamo i nostri meravigliosi savoiardi
- Il mio com'è? (Mario) - E' pazzesco, cioè orribile ma sano
- Toppissimo - Che è il termine tecnico che viene usato! - Toppissimo
Va bene dai...Se lo faccio io va bene lo stesso...Al freezer
- Quello che abbiamo fatto adesso è stata una cosa da asilo
possiamo dirlo si? Infatti dicevo "Cacchio il
livello è un po' basso". Ma vogliamo fare
quello con la bottiglia e vedere se
funziona?
Abbiamo preso una bottiglia dalla spazzatura - Non è la dispensa quella? - Io l'ho provato (Rico) - Funziona?
Hai presente che ogni volta che mangiamo un tiramisù penso sempre "Ma rischio di
morire?" - Esatto si anch'io lo penso. In
realtà dovresti diciamo pastorizzarle con
la meringa o la patabomb - Si, scooby dooby doo
Oddio no! (Irene) - Ma guarda come l'hai fatto! (Rico)
- Cosa ho sbagliato? - No lo devi tenere
premuto vero? - Si devi spremere e poi risucchiarlo e
aspettare che entri dentro (Rico)
- Noo Guglielmo...- Ma è un peccato poi sprecare così - Ma scusa, la colpa di chi è? (Rico)
Allora l'ultima - Secondo me perché non
ci hai creduto veramente...Prova a tenerlo sempre così
Con una paura addosso l'ha fatto (Rico)
- Comunque esperimento riuscito. Savoiardi
che dicono? -  So pronti secondo me. Ci siamo? - Mi sa che l'ho bruciato. "Non ho mai bruciato!"
Vai prendiamo qua...e non lo mischiare! - Ah certo. Io sto fingendo di guardare
Bruciato al punto giusto
Come lo pastorizziamo adesso? - lo scaldiamo al
microonde a 60 gradi, che è una bassa
pastorizzazione, cioè cerchiamo di levare il
peggio capito? .- Ok - Allora 10 grammi di acqua e
40 grammi di zucchero - Tutto qua dentro...
- E poi microonde si
- Io solitamente in realtà non
faccio questo procedimento - Lui le cova
direttamente (Rico) - Si, mi ci siedo sopra un'intera
notte. Ho una domanda, è normale che sappia di c**o l'uovo quando sta nel microonde?
Ci siamo resi conto, usandolo tantissimo il
microonde, che sa popo de c**o
Vabbè è un grembiule insomma, cioè nel senso mo è la prima volta che ti sporchi in vita tua?
Dai per favore!
Questo è il Ghost della pasticceria
Quindi io posso fare "questo" senza paura
di morire...Re Joffrey - Adesso montiamo panna e
mascarpone - Allora si è spenta un secondo la telecamera, quindi non sappiamo se avete
visto il montaggio della panna col mascarpone. Ho rischiato quasi di fare il
burro ma forse è salva - Adesso buttiamo
questa roba qua dentro
e amalgamiamo con delicatezza...sennò si smonta
Basta che la smonti! - Così la smonto? - Si - Ma sei seria? - Certo! - Allora vai tu. Occhio che così la smonti
Ed è pure un po' liquidina per entrare bene...
- Nella sfera, non perché abbiamo smontato...Non toccare troppo con le dita sennò rimangono le ditate
Tiè, perfetto! Dobbiamo fissarla sul
piatto - Sul piatto
- Oddio
- Ho un idea - Vuoi fissarla col cioccolato? - Brava! Do un attimo una passatina per...Cavolo è tutto incrostato
purtroppo...Me l'accollo io... - Non si può bruciare qualcosa che
è già bruciato. Mettilo più dritto che
puoi, perché sennò poi è storta la sfera
Ci siamo si - Non posso credere che forse verrà una ricetta, perché solitamente non viene mai niente
- Non parlare. Non fa la porcata che ti casca tutto fuori...Li dobbiamo rompere perché devono entrare
- Per fortuna lo copriamo... - Anche in pasticceria fanno così vero? - Mamma mia che ansia!
- Pianissimo eh! - Ti prego Irè!
- Noo!
Allora... - Cos'era quello? (Rico) - Niente! - Niente
- E' il momento del gruè - Il momento del gruè - Senza rompere tutto - Così? - Si adesso tu ce lo spargi un po'
intorno così vedi? Gli vogliamo dare una glitterata? - Si. Io non so cosa aspettarmi
Ah, perfetto da tutt'altra parte
Ragazzi è veramente bello da vedere (Mario)
- Sono commossa. Ecco hai dovuto fa...Ecco ci siamo scordati il marsala vabbé - Ci siamo scordati il marsala
ma è meglio per i vostri bambini fidatevi - Esatto!               - Teoricamente la cosa migliore sarebbe cercare
di avere un qualcosa di appuntito, tipo la macchinettina del caffè
piccolina, una cosa per versarlo così ma non ce l'abbiamo. Irene mi sta
sconsigliando in tutti i modi di usare la tazzina perché comincerà a lanciare caffè
ovunque, ma è perché non hai il tocco... - Il tocco da maestro. Hai presente quella maledizione che dicevi
che non viene mai niente qua a Vita Buttata. Se lo versi piano cade da tutte...
- In realtà si è sciolto perché
questo è un savoiardo - Doveva essere più grande per fare... - Per implodere proprio
Comunque possiamo dire che è vera la cosa
cosa che si dice su Cucina Buttata? Io vorrei
passare un attimo all'assaggio.  Oh che figo
- Ah vabbè ragazzi però! (Rico)
- Te sei magnato tutti i savoiardi
- Esperimento del versare la tazzina c'aveva ragione lei
Cercate di avere un bricchettino o un qualcosa
che vi faccio andare... - Si pure un po' più
elegante diciamo... - Di una tazzina? - Che è sta cafonata così... - Irene io ti ringrazio di cuore per esserti prestata a
questa roba qui - E' stato un piacere - So' che i tuoi standard sono più alti
Un po' come Jasmine è bello mischiarsi capito,
insieme ... - Ai plebei? - Gli straccioni
- No, mi sono divertita tantissimo, quindi garzie a te -Grazie a te per la tua falsità
- Ragazzi se volete seguire le sue
creazioni, se volete seguire tutto quello
che fa vi lascio qua sotto i tuoi link, Instagram
Vi metterò qua sotto anche in info box un
sacco di altre, magari informazioni, dalle
dosi a un sacco di altre robe che le ruberò
adesso è che rivenderemo insieme alla
sua maglietta. Noi ci vediamo la prossima
domenica sempre alle 12 con un altro
episodio di Cucina Buttata. Ciao - Ciao